in our series i on earth a new report
shows an alarming drop in worldwide
shark populations this unprecedented
global study finds
sharks have simply vanished from many
places
the research was backed by funding from
the late microsoft co-founder paul allen
before the pandemic in quarantine mark
phillips spent a day at sea with its
lead authors for a story you'll see only
on cbs this morning
good morning we're off the coast of
florida near palm beach
and we're hunting for sharks not because
they're in the news for all the wrong
reasons because in a lot of places
there are too few of them for our own
good
the authors of the study use a simple
contraption with the complicated name
made it remote underwater video or bruv
bruv for short a cage with bait in it at
one end
and a camera at the other okay going in
the water
damien chapman and mike height house
have been part of the most comprehensive
worldwide shark survey ever conducted
did you invent this kind of photo trap
or it was a
pretty pretty common usage say we
perfected it
yeah you drop it overboard and lower it
to the ocean floor
the project they call fin print has done
this over
15 thousand times over four years in 58
countries
the idea is to leave the bruv down there
for an hour and see how many sharks show
up
sometimes in some places quite a few
sometimes none of the almost 400 reefs
that have been surveyed around the world
20 percent of them we didn't see a
single shark but is that in itself an
indicator of the problem
absolutely caught by fishermen sometimes
accidentally
often on purpose to satisfy the growing
shark meat market
populations have crashed she'd come in
right here
in this drop off the florida coast the
pickings were slim
no shock nurse shirt yep big one
sometimes they'll just come in have a
sniff and then just head right away
in fact a loggerhead turtle seemed more
interested in this free lunch than the
sharks were
but by using the same setup recording
for the same amount of time on each drop
around the world
the researchers have been able to draw
the first comprehensive
database conclusions about worldwide
shark numbers
do you think the population is under
crisis oh i absolutely think this is a
crisis
but a different kind of crisis one with
the new term
the word extinction gets thrown around
verge of extinction virtual extinction
what have you do you use that phrase
well for our survey we use the term
functional extinction
functional extinction meaning there may
be some sharks around
but there are not enough of them to
perform their essential role
of controlling other marine populations
you might think hey let's get rid of
predators that eat fish so we can have
more fish
but it actually doesn't work that way
you lose predators their prey explode
and they eat themselves out of house and
home
when you lose top predators ecosystems
tend to start to unravel
there are bright spots in this study
where marine protection zones have been
introduced
or fishing restrictions tighten so that
fewer sharks are caught
their numbers have begun to come back
some people will be sitting at home
saying
why are we worried about these sharks
they don't get a great press well sharks
definitely need a new pr agency
but what we're really seeing is that you
need to have healthy shark populations
you need to have healthy reefs and
that's going to ultimately help people
too
this study isn't only about gathering
knowledge it's about gathering
ammunition a way to convince governments
and fish and communities around the
world
to do something sharks don't get great
press gail but we sure do need them
yeah i know and i didn't really realize
that until you start really reading and
learning about them he's absolutely
right
don't don't disparage the sharps they
are badly badly needed and make a big
difference in the environment
even though they are very scary